[Music]
repeat offender news submitted by do a
mukbang please I've been doing them I've
been doing them to [ __ ] lay on the
phone kind of doing right now - I'm
starving
yeah you need to watch your personal
channels mukbang let's go I'm talking
about my life hey what's up I love boys
and yeah this is no mum I think you know
more these are you he's pretending to be
a mukbang girl ya know I'm up mind wrong
pretty good
why can't you be a mukbang boy and wash
them that's the same thing they just eat
yeah I've actually never watched mukbang
boys I haven't either
well my mom's are different because Ava
doesn't do that yeah I would go in
pretty hardcore and my [ __ ] was getting
a little expensive so yo man your sushi
was so good oh yeah I was like making my
own food and I was gonna bring people in
to eat the food and they're gonna do the
bond for me yeah I create the food you
eat it oh she's like the best for
everybody yeah David's mukbang video
with me was just me talking about his
food yeah I don't have to be on camera
but I get to create food problem was
that [ __ ] was tiring as [ __ ] it was hard
like six hours of cooking yeah because
that was like super 8 you got like a
[ __ ] ton of use for them though yeah but
then you know what I was exhausted and
you're after a while like I just I have
a lot of food leftover - and I'm not
gonna eat sushi for the rest of the
[ __ ] week you know oh that's true cuz
to make like a couple pieces you need to
get the whole so I'll just making sushi
for everybody hey Wow and like thanks
for the invite I know literally ended No
and Joe were the last ones and then I
was like oh so I made like ramen from
scratch for her yeah
and that [ __ ] was tiring his [ __ ] it's
because you wasn't good that's the
leftover that leave no Gigli have even
known if you meet the wrong informs ones
are good it could've been packaged you
know she's thinking wasn't good you like
to go hardcore there's a middle ground
but you always pass that to do it right
you know what it is too cuz I also don't
like cooking food if I can't make it as
happy as I get it when I ordered I'm
doing a mukbang tip I met a boy earlier
like a woman who have been arrested 39
times in eight years was arrested again
for stealing an active ambulance why is
there no darkstrike over there where's
the [ __ ] that was in there get the [ __ ]
out of here she's been playing too much
GTA that game is kind so insane man all
I can spot the graphics has gotten so
much better it looks real how Wow
and it looks like I left you know you
could just drive around in LA yeah but
you can't [ __ ] hookers and kill people
without you [ __ ] hookers anymore you can
well you can but it's not you can not in
the game it's a different political
climate I'm driving a military vehicle I
can't [ __ ] a hooker in it and that I
just takes me right out of the game did
you know the new spider-man game is like
the new GTA oh really you can go out
there and do [ __ ] like that because
[ __ ] in it maybe in your [ __ ]
Spidey costume she webs in between a new
GT or a father did you say that you get
their numbers I heard the news fighting
game has the most accurate depiction of
New York ever except for the World Trade
Center because it's copy written so they
couldn't use the actual trades that are
in one world center world whatever the
Mauryan rule in there you should so the
tower itself right is copy written so
you can't use the exact Eiffel Tower so
they made like a dummy tower I guess in
the spider-man game to make it look
similar but it's not the same on
Leamas
how do you order picked a piece of the
New York skyline so that people can't
use its depiction where the Eiffel Tower
to do that yeah but they had the Eiffel
Tower in the game somehow fake one in
New York no in the spider-man game in
what a good like it takes place in New
York yeah yeah yeah
spider-man's in New York TIF I know so
I'm like I was there and I will tower
and there hello tip but I'm pretty tired
of you mimic playing video okay I'm
pretty tired either my mukbang video
anyway let me tell you about this crazy
lady sorry name is Christie she's from
Oregon she's 37 and she's been arrested
for her 39th time she surpassed her
arrest of her years that she's lived
that's amazing wow that's amazing job
Christie amazing yeah so this proud of
you this girl she's had about a hundred
and fourteen charges the majority of
them are for disorderly conduct
trespassing criminal mischief harassment
and violating parole oh I'm gonna show
you all of her mugshot no no I have a
ton of her mug shot what the [ __ ] jeez
she's like cheese oh she's like what a
lot more uh you think you can god damn
dude it's like different ha ha it's like
different ages of Christie she could
have an Instagram she looks so different
she could have a whole Instagram theme
of her mug shots yeah smoking crack dude
she looks like she could have been a
really cute well put together person
mm-hmm and the drugs got her have you
seen like before-and-after meth photos
of people that just started and in like
people that are like full-blown madman
seen it in real life and in celebrities
to do their celebrity accounts of that
counts yeah of
where they just do that [ __ ] the
biggest face change ever in Hollywood
history Mickey Rourke oh yeah he was a
good looking mother [ __ ] dude what he
was a model and app you can get addicted
to plastic surgery
looks like he filled his face up with
water it's crazy
that's like that bad zaza or the Gabor
Logan top twins have you seen those kind
big control the world first of all and
their Bo GaN do ffs
what did they do they're like models in
Britain or they're like in the UK nuts
bro turn it around show what on let me
let me love this image Wow what the [ __ ]
whoa so they got plastic surgery to look
like this what the [ __ ] oh I've seen
that before they got elastic surgery to
try to look like Jordan Peele and if
favored it looks like a cartoon okay
they were a look at whether he Headroom
remember Max Headroom he did that on
purpose yeah why did I do that oh
they're just old they're trying to
maintain their youth they look like
dolls like those like scary haunted
dolls they look like a cartoon character
drawing of Neil Diamond they look like
the people who control the world which
is the mean about them is that they
secretly control the money supply and
everything in the what good looks
I don't remember it's one of those know
your main things that I don't remember
it's like in the crypto community
everyone believes that they control the
prices of things because there's a
couple videos that went viral about them
telling people to dump Bitcoin and buy
it and it's pretty funny stuff actually
it was a great video people are so sad
man you're gonna get old it's gonna
happen you're gonna age and you're gonna
die that's a fact
whatever it's funny when their face is
all tight here and then they got this
[ __ ] wrinkled [ __ ] yeah cuz we can't
do anything about that part yeah you
like facelift oh you can oh and it
tightens it up
I think cuz my grandma's obviously she's
got like big cuts something behind your
ears or something I don't remember the
skid point is I've been lift everything
like facing everyone yeah I think it
comes from people that like identify
themselves and their value through look
look like models like actors and people
that have like like if their whole thing
is about like sex appeal yeah look about
what's her name Monica Geller what's her
real name she stopped doing her face
[ __ ] her like injections and stuff now
she looks back to normal really she
looks great she was already [ __ ] says
yes she openly put it out she goes you
know I got a little obsessed with it and
she goes I'm alright now
I'm fine now her face is normally she
looks great I thought you
not coming back from that I thought it
was permanent yeah yeah she looks oh
yeah she looks back it looks like nice
that song and she's so [ __ ] pretty do
she look like a bogan not before all
yeah exactly
that's crane let's radicular high cheek
[ __ ] the [ __ ] everything is with that
why do people get lip fillers that [ __ ]
freaks me out lips are like the one we
kissed your lips thin over time and so
you want like you have full lips yeah so
that your lipstick looks good and says
it was just a thin line dude like Jenna
Jameson's but thing was pretty much
because sometimes they go too far
because they're like a little bit is not
enough lips are one of those things that
when you alter it just never looks right
yeah you could tell right off the bat it
looks terrible
yeah well in photos they look good but
in person weird you think Kylie Jenner's
lips look weird yeah they look like a
goldfish I don't know which ones with
hers were so thin that now that it looks
normal which ones Kendall and Kylie's
the one has a baby and he's worth like
they're doing the Kylie Jenner lip
challenge really all right like she
doesn't even this girl doesn't even look
like herself anymore oh wow that
actually worked out she had no upper lip
yeah yeah now she took out the fillers
again that's what they made headlines
she looks fantastic though let's undo
them everything's fake hey if it looks
good yeah that's like Vegas right like
Vegas is fake as [ __ ] but it looks
amazing I love it I love how fake it is
right it makes it so fun it does if you
get away with it and bring on the fake I
love how you compete but it's just like
Vegas where things get old fast and it's
just like Vegas when you put too much
light on it it looks nuts yeah you had a
Vegas ass face girl yeah and it's just
like Vegas well it will suck you dry
shoes like now oh I should sort of make
ups she looks so much better here yeah
the second one I disagree you like you
like more I like am ethnic yeah yeah I
like them but imagine semen person
though like she look like yeah I guess
most people don't see them in person
she's so much better here dude I know I
like
less fillers I do I'd wait what about
this lady with all these charges gossipy
right listen you're in my mukbang video
okay we're talking about what I want I
mean there's nothing else I can tell you
other than the fact that she's been
arrested 39 times a multi criminal great
she took this ambulance while it was
being used yeah what happened to that
patient and her only to be died the only
thing was well why did they leave it
unlocked that's was like that is a bear
fault no she's a cluck though and she
gets like if she can get away with it
why he just wanted a ride to go get a
pack of cigarettes
yeah our cop car is always unlocked yeah
they're always running if Sofia Vergara
got work done that doctor deserves a big
tip cuz she looks fantastic so here's a
tip got a big old Pingel big old tip big
[Music]